I think you guys for coming out to
another strategy session tonight we're
gonna spotlight another one of our
members here to spend here a member for
a long time played in hundreds of
tournaments here at the Chess Club
tonight we welcome Mario Roper to the
show you may know him from his blitz
bounty with Mike comer and other stuff
on our YouTube channel he's been a
regular for quite a long time now so
thanks Mario for coming on and we're
gonna check out some of your games and
what if I guess your most your most
famous game at least around here we're
gonna look at tonight this is the game
Mario Roper versus national master Jim
McLaughlin and well spoil it a little
bit you were you did win this yeah I did
win against the national master this was
a standard rated game and I guess it was
the day at the blitz tournament you just
beat another master is that yeah man it
should be another man saying this long
yeah it was national master Nick Carlo
you're able to take him down so he does
have a couple master scalps under his
belt
so yeah Mario does have some some pretty
good wins and you know there's times
when he plays particularly well and so
we're gonna look at the first game today
which is his game against Jim McLoughlin
from the show-me classic 2015
okay so Mario had the white pieces in
this game and they started off with a
very very theoretical opening an open
Sicilian that quickly became a knight
Orff
do you face this a lot as white I don't
think so maybe you know once in a while
hopefully I remember the lines
accurately okay and yeah I see typically
sort of an unusual move here the move
Bishop to d3 though I was surprised in
the database Carlsen played this one
time so okay you're in decent company
there the more popular moves are like
Bishop to g5 or Bishop to e3 also
popular moves with this Bishop is either
Bishop to e2 or Bishop to c4 so those
are the most typical moves in this
position you went here which perhaps is
a good square if blacks ever castled and
get to move your EEP on and you sack
here and you check me home but there is
the risk that he could end up behind
this pawn here on the like square so
it's not entirely clear that that's the
best square for the bishop but all right
if world champions can play it they
can't be the worst a little you could
play in the position now he went 45
which i think is very logical you know
so in this position in typical and
knight Orff's they try to play e5 and
later their goal is going to be to try
to play d5 and i guess it was already an
interesting decision that has to be made
so you need to move your your knight
somewhere yeah and I guess we'll just
ask the audience we'll try to get the
audience involved right away to face
with this decision you have to move your
night where were you guys
move your knight already in this
position okay and you want to bring this
guy over here and so just looking at the
spawn structure so this is actually what
was played in the game and I think we're
gonna see to why this move is a little
bit unusual if you just look at the palm
structure in this position there's one
square if you just imagine the board
without any pieces on it that you really
need to consider in this pawn structure
and that's this square d5 as white you
really want to control d5 so this Bishop
perhaps would be better on c4 in a
position like this where you're never
gonna let them play d5 and often this
Bishop will go to g5 where you can
remove one of the defenders of d5 that's
a typical theme in this structure so I
think for that reason this was already
sort of a unusual move so I think
perhaps you could have waited with this
guy or you could have already put them
on c4 and also okay if you do play
Knight f3 then obviously it's gonna be
difficult to play a move like f4 in the
future which is a very typical idea here
with white whether you've castled king
or queen side that's a very common move
and sometimes you can play a 5 and then
g4 g5 and you attack as as Mario seems
to like to do you seem to like to attack
so I mean so perhaps more typical for
this type of opening would have been
Knight to b3 this is sort of the usual
one just keeping clear of the F pawn and
okay sometimes this is a useful defender
over here on the Queen side alright we
had nine f3 in the game
Bishop e7 black just prepares to castle
and now this move h3 which I don't
particularly like and I think this this
was played a long time ago I mean it was
more than a year ago so I know that's
that's something you had this habit of
always playing h3 or H six in every game
so what what why did you play h3 odds
we've bent the knife from going to h4 I
mean the g4 and also the bishop and I
was also playing on castling queenside
okay and I guess to if I'm looking at
this well definitely in this position if
we play some random move like it's not
like we're really afraid of Knight to g4
if there's no real follow up here and
then I can always kick you back at some
point if I want to and then you just
kind of wasted a lot of time so in this
position I don't think I'm particularly
afraid of 90 g4 I don't think that's
really a threat and I also think it
would be ill-advised let's just make a
total waste move here I don't think he
really is threatening to go here because
as we've mentioned with this structure
is all about d5 which is a light square
so you you really shouldn't be worried
about something with him giving away his
light squared bishop because that'll
actually end up giving you more control
over d5 and you can continue with an
idea sometimes of taking this night and
if you can get an endgame with a knight
on d5 versus you know a bad bishop maybe
on f6
that's sort of a dream endgame that
you're you're hoping to get in this pawn
structure okay so we go back ok h3 I
think is it's too slow and it stops a
fake threat so okay Jim just cancelled
very reasonable and here again I think
this is just sort of uh you know and I
think you've actually gotten a lot bad
or better at this but it's just sort of
okay just some natural developing move
but without putting much thought into
the actual demands of this exact
concrete position because again I think
perhaps in this line the bishop should
go to g5 because you might take one of
the defenders of d5 which is the most
important element of this position and
even moving this Bishop again might not
be such a horrible move either just
getting control over d5 so that's there
should be the the main focus in this
but okay we'll see what happens here so
he plays b5
okay very logical move he might play
before you know he's getting ready to
kick your night around he might also put
the Bishop on b7 where then before would
threatened to remove the knight from the
defense of e4 so that would be something
here just Queen d2 okay very good move
and now Mario does something aggressive
which he's known to do Oh
g4 okay he's he's not afraid he's
playing a national master but he's gonna
go for it here comes Mario Bishop v7 and
I guess I guess you could consider
playing a3 but I know you you playing on
castling over there so perhaps you
didn't want to do that which is
understandable so now you played the
move g5 and here I don't think Jim
actually found the best move yeah I
think the best move here is something
that a lot of people have difficulty
coming up with do you know what it is
does the audience know all that will try
to get the audience into this
if you guys were black okay they
attacked your night so it says this is
exactly what he played in the game which
is okay but I think but I can actually
do a little bit better here
I mean h5 is a great square for the
night you know sometimes we're gonna
jump into f4 yeah yeah in this position
he can play b4 mm-hmm yeah right so if
we take here you take here and you're on
the Queen and you do have sort of an
issue you really don't want to take with
a pawn and just destroy your pawn
structure on the Queen side yeah I was
actually afraid at this in the game but
he didn't do that right yeah and if you
take with the Queen well at some point
one of these rooks might end up going to
a C file getting some tempo on the Queen
and it's really opened up the Queen side
more than the Kings side so after okay
let's take this first you know now we're
just we're ready to at some point I can
even maybe move my Queen somewhere and
get my rook into the game somehow this
might end up being kind of dangerous for
you and okay also I do have some
pressure here on the e4 which is really
nice yeah and how do I defend this I
have to move my knight yeah if you have
to play move like 92 then okay black
should definitely consider playing like
this well I mean okay so as white you
just one taken here you'd have to move
your knight and you'll notice so if he
moves here he loses a pawn
okay but you might you might have to
play a move like this Knight to d5 how
does this lose upon you take with this
okay right yeah so yeah it's not quite
winning the pawn because I can check my
pick up the bishop because but even if
he you know you don't win this even if
you don't take this you know right away
this is a positional success for black
because he's able to this guy is no
longer weak because now you're not going
to be able to attack
so this and okay now you have pressure
on this guy and I can increase my
pressure you know I have nights it can
increase the pressure so I actually have
a target now so this would be quite a
success for black and it's very typical
in I mean a lot of Sicilians where this
happens where they attack your knight on
f6 and you can respond by attacking the
knight on c3 especially when you gain
more tempo because you're taking the
blame so okay
oh yeah in the game he did decide he's
just gonna go to h5 and I mean black
might very well be better already just
because you know there's been some you
know less than the most accurate moves
here going on in the opening but okay so
this plays out here now okay so yeah
this is actually an interesting idea and
again I don't know if this is absolutely
the best but okay you want to come into
f5 and he stopped you so he did have to
make a move in front of his King which
perhaps he didn't want to do well will
you really be able to ever exploit that
I guess that's what we're gonna try to
see all right so now you decide to
castle makes a lot of sense
you know this position okay you wanna
play Bishop e2 so I assumed just point
was he was gonna go to f4 you you want
to take this
it's good
yeah because we'll get Queen I take your
name yeah I try not to do that yeah so
then something a similar tactic will
what happened here in the game cuz after
he Castle he just did it now Knight to
f4 okay and I guess I'll again test the
audience what do you think the best way
to handle this position here as white
what's the best thing we can do here and
you can always pause at home too if you
need more time I think there is
something to be said for taking this
night immediately okay
and we understand this tactic so it's a
similar to what we had just seen okay
they can take here
yeah so we can move the knight now and
if here okay so we can trade and okay
maybe we can play here and wherever you
go
maybe here and I'm getting ready maybe I
can play h4 h5 if I can swing the Queen
over so I mean okay this is definitely a
consideration but in the game you win
here and he wasn't tempted in taking
this right away and it's not really
Jim's style anyway he's you know he
wants to probably just keep this close
he's not too worried about material in
general that's yeah if I if I know Jim
let's see ok b4 okay another really
aggressive forceful move so you can
always do this and you can win this
later all right so the night went back
to e2 okay now we're taking this night
with a lot of stuff so he decided to
grab the LightSquared bishop okay it's
very sensible and you check back and now
a5 and okay I guess white does have this
plan he's gonna go here he's gonna open
up yeah the stuff black has ideas of
Bishop to a6
you know these ideas like a for b3 yeah
so this is a very sort of a typical
Mario game you know everything is really
complicated and both sides are gonna be
attacking each other so I think this
what's really good about this game not
like did you you know play really well
it's you really played Mario style so
this really isn't a lot more your style
than it is
Jim's style he is a older gentleman very
positional he's really strong and
maneuvering and that sort of thing so I
think this actually is a great opening
to give yourself you know I could try to
actually win this game so I think this
has been going really well
okay h4 here you come the attacks are
Queen I see it you see it all right
excellent
now a4 yeah whose attack is gonna land
first well all right Mario was getting
for it and then an interesting move I
think here was played Queen to a5 which
I thought was interesting I guess this
point at least I thought his point was
used cuz I okay now he wants to play b3
at some point because that'll help open
up the stuff but okay you can't do it on
the very next move because of the Queen
hanging but maybe at this point is he's
gonna play Queen to b5 gain a tempo on
the night and then be ready to play b3
on the next move something sharp like
that
okay this move 9 h4 yeah I guess you
have to get your night out of the way
cuz in so many lines I feel like I need
to move my F pawn and then swing this
Queen over here and meet you on the H
file somehow okay yeah Bishop c4 okay so
he's attacking your pawn it's also maybe
he's gonna help defend he can go back
here if he needs to and okay you could
play a move like king b1 I think that's
a very sensible move and I think you can
also do what Mario did he took on g6 and
I guess I'll test the audience again I
mean I guess your options are well you
can take on a2 or you can take back on
g6 so there's two ways to do it so if
you guys are faced with this position is
black what would you do here because
these are you know really sharp
positions this is a typical Knight Orff
opposite side castling very sharp very
aggressive stuff but what would you guys
do here is black
what's the question you can take on a -
or you can take back one of two ways on
g6 I believe well he took he took on 1
g7 he took on g7 I mean yeah so he they
yeah you did take this way which I think
is correct it is sort of dangerous
ticking back this way and with the pawn
here you can always play rook to f7 so
here there might already be some sort of
tricks like I want to move this out of
the way plant one of these nights here
with my F pawn and swing my Queen over
yeah you do have to be really careful as
black when you're when you're doing this
because even a move like King to g7
might not be a good enough defense
because I'm in a second Knight bring the
Queen over to the H file I can they can
get scary pretty fast so I think that
would just be wrong this also looks like
this could get really really dangerous I
got to decide I can I can take first I
can also probably toss this move in but
uh okay I can take this and you're
probably not gonna take me but you know
I'm coming in here and maybe I'm
sometimes I'm gonna sack this guy
sometimes this guys come in in this also
can get really dangerous and I think
waits attack actually here should be a
lot stronger like if you just make some
silly move I can play here my next move
is here and bad stuff will probably
happen for black quicker than it'll
happen for weight but okay so in the
game he took back which is definitely
the safest and it's probably the most
correct and now if you ever do stuff on
the H file I at least have rook to f7 to
defend King b1 okay very good movie is
attacking your pawn and with all the
stuff that's gonna happen here that's
probably a great place for your king so
an interesting decision here too he
played the move b3 which does give Mario
the chance to trade Queens if he wants
yeah so it's also still possible to play
move like Queen b5 gain a tempo on the
night and only then b3
and refused to trade the Queens so and
here all ask the class and then last
Mario well sleeping fur which which way
actually it would be better so should
you trade the Queens here or should you
play as Mario did Knight to c3 I don't
really know the the right answer to that
so we'll see what what the audience
would do because if you do train Queens
it's you know you don't get made it as
much yes you're taken here yes I guess I
go here or something see because what
actually I'm in okay so in the game
makes the c5 was played here yes I guess
here I'm just gonna move over so I guess
we're looking at this is that you're
looking at might be so now I really want
to trade the Queens okay yeah yeah yeah
King b1 was a very important move yeah
if your king is over here maybe they
take on e2 and then they make a queen
okay so why did this is a decision I
guess I would like to know from you I
mean it's it's a tough decision to make
should you trade the Queens or should
you play Knight to c3 what led you to to
this decision rather than trading the
Queens I knew in this and this way of
playing um to keep the Queens on a boy
and generate continued Jerry attack okay
so you still think you have a lot of
potential for an attack here some would
yeah and you think that's stronger than
whatever Black has over here it's it's
like it's a race you don't really know
yes I guess a lot here you do have to
use a lot of judgment right its am I
gonna be faster is he gonna be faster
and I guess did he did you see anything
concrete for either of you or was it
just sort of intuitive he was intuitive
very intuitive positions but I knew that
I didn't want to trade trade then I'm
pretty sure he's more tactical in the
endgame mm-hmm yes I guess I probably do
with this I would probably trade the
Queens because I guess I'm kind of more
scared that he's gonna be faster over
here I don't exactly see what I'm gonna
do yet but I know what he's gonna do
he's gonna take on these pawns he's
gonna play a three you know that sort of
thing but this actually does actually
help you out because I don't know I mean
do you remember at the time situation
was here already cuz he was using lots
and lots of time I remember um I believe
I'm mayapan maybe five or six minutes
and he was less than three already in
this position so there's already already
when was a pretty serious time pressure
if I remember right it's a game in 65
yeah and okay yeah so okay it sounds
like already there was you have to make
some yeah pretty intuitive quick
decisions which okay that the time
scramble actually ends up helping Mario
in the long run here but he went for
Knight to c5 okay he's just improving
his pieces yeah okay it's a very
reasonable move f3 perhaps you're a
queen can sometimes slide over and now
this move a three and then somewhere
around here I think a mistake was made
okay you took here which i think is
right I think actually yes are here Wow
I mean if you guys can figure out the
best continuation here as black who can
play like Komodo in this position so
there's actually a winning attack here
for black that you know you got to be a
computer to see so here you may want to
pause your videos at home so you can
find the remarkable win the gym could
have found here and you were talking
about at some point maybe there was a
win missed was it around this time that
it's possible I'm not yeah cuz I think
the computer here found you know very
very remarkable combination
Bishop d3 check is the the start which
is perhaps the easier move of the the
next two to find here and if you go here
yes it's that mean it's over you can
take your check you can take care and
the Queen comes in so something like
this would be checkmate the computer
wants you to take here which obviously
loses if you go here there's I think
taking on b2 also wins but can you play
the the monster most accurate computer
move here I mean this is a real
challenge here so the move I don't think
many people would consider even if you
tell them it's a tactic they still want
to consider it yeah this might work okay
so I mean I can't take on my King just
like I have to go here
and now I don't know what's going on
because I'm also on your bishop so if
you you know bring your rook over I can
take on d3 yes and I don't know what's
going on I suppose we can we can check
this move to the knight tank see if that
actually is a jhump28 way over there
we'll put it here so somehow we'll put
it over here so the audience could see
yes this move should win as well so
after this taking you take here have to
take what the Queen d5 is the winning
idea yeah and then it wants you to go
here doesn't you take it if let's just
be greedy for a second to see what
happens here let's take this Bishop III
okay so that does indeed win as well but
in this position after King to c1
there's an even more remarkable move and
it doesn't have to do with the fact that
okay as white your next move might be to
take to this night because okay the
Knights sacking itself on be three and
all sorts of lines and with that in mind
I'll give it away so pause at home if
you want to think about it more the
computer wants you to play this very
cruel move Bishop to g5 hmm just with
the idea of maintaining this Knight here
for as long as possible and okay now I
just casually bring a rock end and my
attack is even stronger so I'm still
sacking on b3 and taking on engineers so
I don't want you to like run away and
then it's X all of its stuff computer
style and finds the crushing mate there
okay but okay so it seems like this also
could've been a continuation he could
have found fun but again with such
little time and start to play something
so committal like that because with the
bishop here you do have to be worried I
might take your knight which would
remove the defender of the bishop you
know if you're here and you don't see
that if these sacrifices work or not you
don't have time to figure it out you
know it's it's kind of risky because
okay maybe I take there
then I removed the defender so does this
one this no what happened what happened
was a knight takes b3 yeah and you
things might not actually be so clear
anymore
though I think here another mistake was
made it is just a move I couldn't
actually read my own notation so either
one here you went to H - do you remember
jewelry one I think you in here you will
see - Lucy - okay yeah I think you have
to take this yeah I mean so when they're
sacking pieces like this I mean I know
it's tough but this night is too strong
here you have to at least remove some of
their defenders so when he's sacking
like this you do have to kind of accept
it and accept whatever the consequences
of this are and it actually works oh you
know okay for you I think you defend
here for example if he takes this you
know I have a very good move there's one
move here that you have to find so we'll
test your defensive skills and Mario's I
guess at the same time what what would
you guys do here there is a defense here
for wipe it obviously looks looks a
little scary cuz I'm getting attacked a
lot but we can finally move here whoa
we'll survive yeah 95 yes this is a
great move asking to trade the Queens
I'm attacking the bishop and okay that
doesn't give you time to do a whole lot
so yeah you can play a move like this
and okay I don't know what black should
play here but if your next move you get
to trade the Queens then they've
defended so yeah you can win an exchange
like back if he wants but you'll trade
some stuff and yeah okay so they
actually probably want some defense here
instead you just moved the Queen and now
he takes here
okay trying to keep it closed yeah and I
think pretty soon all this build-up
Mario now play it I don't know do you
member how much time yet here cuz I
think this is actually is the final
booth which I don't know if you played
you know the best move or anything here
but you played the most confusing and
then you lost one time so that's you
know that's one of the big strategies so
here just and you know I guess Jim's
confused he doesn't know exactly what to
play and it's kind of scary cuz he okay
you take the night but maybe Mike we
know what's happening you open up a file
right yeah you're gonna open up a file
like yeah so he could either probably
take this yeah we're gonna take back
maybe you're gonna swing your queen in
maybe you're maybe gonna play the here
you know so there's all sorts of
complicated stuff you know I'm trying to
maybe get some stuff going here on the H
file and okay so I do you remember how
much time you actually had when you play
this move I might have had maybe four
minutes in and I waited for about two
minutes and he was down to like the last
minute and yeah for ii just kept
thinking and kept lactis I you know I
felt comfortable but I felt comfortable
with the sacrifice he was trying to the
same thing to me yeah Wow okay so yeah I
mean so that's fantastic and okay some
mistakes were made when both players
here were you know facing a lot of time
pressure but it does sound like okay you
played sort of better under pressure you
play it a little bit faster yeah and
you've played some complicated moves
that really asked them didn't take it
out for them yeah right I mean yes he's
got to be really careful you know if I
take so that kind of have to take but I
wonder all the consequences of taking
and all right that's kind of how you
want to play in in time pressure you
want to especially especially in there
time pressure make them sort it out and
come up with stuff and maybe if he moves
too quickly he'll make a mistake and
okay sometimes maybe they don't move at
all and then you win so okay a big
congrats Mario on your first win against
the national master that's pretty
awesome and we will take a look at Mario
Roper versus Club favorite Ken West
and this was during the Sinquefield
action quads from this year right this
was yes the game from this year so mario
has white against Ken Ken who's been on
the show recently yeah he was up here
doing one of these member spotlight
editions with dual commentary so extra
quad so it's probably game twenty
minutes three second delay sound right
alright and you guys played a London
system and now for a novelty so this is
a you know pretty well known London
system and now in this position after
Knight to c6 we got to move a four which
is not a move so we've got the Roper
variation of the London system why did
you play a four to gain space to gain
space and it's funny because he copied
you I don't know why didn't you like
develop a piece I figured I can get away
with you know I'm playing someone closer
to my rating yes you can get away with
it yeah he responded in kind
so we do want to be careful we want to
see who's you know how their space
affects us well with our pun here
one good thing for white I mean
especially I think blacks a5 is worse
than your a4 because he doesn't have
access to this square but on the other
hand you do have access to some squares
now you can put a bishop there you could
put a knight on d5 you can do that sort
of a deal so I think a 45 probably
favors you just because he's given up
more squares than you have it's not so
normal developing loose and b3 yes I
think when I talk about this because I
guess you're we are you is this aimed at
preventing c4 or something yes I'm like
the I guess I just wanted I wanted to go
at a slow pace and then just castle and
then just may I just made a weight move
do you think this is something you
should avoid less like castle like let's
let's give let's give him this okay
Jake is this good for you or him do you
think these bad families get in the
strong pawn structure and it's all
blocking my bishop on the Queen side
okay well I think if he does do this
because I guess do we also want to kind
of figure where each side wants to play
yeah so he doesn't want to play on this
side of the board he has more space you
know the deep once's advanced pawn here
and his pawns are pointing this way so
he does want to play on this side of the
board however if he releases the tension
in the center I think it's actually
gonna help you be able to play a move
like 'if or in the future and now you
don't have to worry about stuff over
there on the Queen side anymore and you
can get on with your advance which is
you know II four maybe five if he
doesn't take it and that's sort of a
thing so in general in these types of
positions where it's any black shouldn't
be playing over here but the tension
really does favour him you know you're
probably not gonna take at any given
moment I mean I just take back with the
bishop
so here's nothing to fear so I think you
you're again you've you know you're
preventing your opponent from doing sort
of a bad plan what you want to you try
to avoid obviously in general you want
it they have a bad plan you want to let
them do it
Bishop d7 which is a legal developing
move I don't know the deeper point I
think is just developing okay you're
taking aim at the H pawn and again
you'll see Mario not castling this is
sort of his style
he's not gonna Castle and and maybe
he'll get an attack going so Ricky hey
and you know blacks making some some
legal moves h4 which i think is is a
good strategy I think h4 is a pretty
good move here you know you're not
cancelling and here you come you're
gonna go get Ken you're gonna go get
them any place the move g6
and I don't know if this is exactly
sound or not it is a rapid game after
all
Mario decided I'll take this opportunity
to play a move age 5 and he took it so
he plays rook takes this is his idea now
I don't know if all of this is exactly
sound but ok and it's a blitz game
you're playing somebody you know your
own rating you're playing kind of West
you know I think any bike now does have
to be really really careful this is this
is quite exciting you know
and Mario Roper games tend to be pretty
exciting in general so that's why it's
it's a pleasure to get you know to talk
about them with you
f5 ok he really don't know anything
happening on that diagonal ok you bring
a king in the route goes to h1 this is
perfect rook g8 ok I guess he's aiming
that undefended pawn all right you
attack his pawn he defends it very good
you know you go in Knight to e5 ok so I
think this has been very logical play I
guess I'll just ask the audience I guess
is this sacrifice sound or not so it's
some people are not in their heads like
very enthusiastically so yeah that's
lots of people say yes does anyone
disagree nope
does the computer disagree probably
because you're down material the
computer disagrees TV is what's given to
us okay
yeah computers very materialistic let's
say the computer will put it over here
so other people home can see all right
it's about equally flex flex a little
bear like to play h4 which was played
all right so he took here first okay so
yeah the computer doesn't like it when
you give away your material so yeah I
kind of kind of figured as much
you took here and now I think you know
sort of a controversial decision here
was was playing you jump with the pond
which I don't quite understand you know
okay you're blocking in
this is Bishop this crazy bishop that
you know can go like this
you're blocking in the bishop here and I
think also okay maybe now his Center is
a little more mobile maybe at some point
now I can play a move like d4 is there
something you feared what this is there
a reason you didn't go for for this move
keeping your bit up on the clear
diagonal here I don't know I just I just
felt like I wanted to take with a pawn
and stay with the bishop yeah okay if I
take with the bishop did I get to pull
on King yes I can move my king or play a
Bishop f6 somewhere else okay I'll just
play here for example yeah and you can
you know I mean okay now probably just
Knight f3 though and okay you're never
gonna want to enter this sort of
scenario or my good night versus your
bad Bishop occurs so you probably don't
want you probably want to avoid that as
black so I don't know I think something
like this would be just fine for you but
it was just sort of an intuitive I guess
I said I just wanted to keep the bish
asparagus hmm I mean sure the knight
would have been I would have given up
the bishop it was drawn nigh by right
yeah so here he's obviously not obliged
to take your your bishop right though
you can always take his bishop and play
your knight here now yes and I think too
just based on okay you have to make
these decisions sort of quickly and a
lot of these games yeah and just as a
general rule - I think you want to keep
bishops on open diagonals yeah and I
think the the closed position over here
is actually kind of good for you I don't
really want to mobilize the center
because now every move you have to you
know be thinking about these different
sacrifices and how that might open up
and expose your king so okay this is
what happened and he wants to Train
bishops with ug3
so now if he takes you can you know have
a really solid Center and that's exactly
what happens and you took back okay and
now I think one of the big questions in
this position a lot has changed we
in the dark squared bishop but this guy
is this a strong outside past bond or is
this a weakness I think I think that's
what a lot of the rest of this game is
gonna be Ken white you know muster up a
bunch of attackers and get that each
pawn or is he going to slowly stroll
down the board and it'll cause you a lot
of problems I think that now we have
that's sort of an issue so okay this
also is a possible contender just making
sure he doesn't have a passed pawn I
don't actually know which one my guess
is the audience is another tricky
position should you take back towards
the center which makes sense you know
for that reason but it does give like a
passed pawn or should you take away from
the center which okay does prevent the
pass pawn but now maybe moves like d4 or
c4 might be stronger and some lines how
would you guys display here yeah you
take with a jeep on okay why you keep
the center strong I think that's yeah I
think that's very reasonable
I'm saying what you want to take the
other way and now a totally separate
question you want to take this way which
way does comodo want to take well I
think it's funny here if you say well
comodo wants to take the other way and
then I want to play the worst move
that's funnier Komodo
yeah it takes the other way for a second
it couldn't decide take what the ebon
take one right well also you know humans
were playing so it's always whichever
way you did something it's the other way
that's that's just how it is when humans
play every move is always a blunder even
if you watch top level games every move
is inaccurate and yeah
computer rates every move everyone ever
plays but okay she took this way which I
think in its own way is reasonable even
though the computer says you're like
minus one
I guess you're down upon you sacrificed
a new you know you're done opponent yes
those computers they're greedy yeah all
right h4 okay
King f1 okay very reasonable you're
bringing a king over for the defense you
know you should be too and I'm thinking
in this position you you wanted to play
a move like rook to f3 but now he would
take it yeah
so you went here traded those guys okay
Wow okay we want to get kind of
aggressive up here okay you're taking it
back okay now and can I defend it all do
you have a threat okay cause me great
grief
all right here you paint it with the
rook I guess I'll get out of the pin
yeah okay stop pinning me
that's be careful here because now
you're going here okay yeah I think I'm
gonna give two I'm gonna give you that
guy if you're one of them hmm just kind
of scary in his own way I notice somehow
something I probably have a more
accurate defense but you take it whoops
cuz I guess I'm going here was my plan
mm-hmm I'm on your night to someone
there's a cleanup stakes in this
position okay you wanna play Queen f6
and keep the pen okay please please
straight with me no you take it here mmm
very interesting I don't know yes this
actually is it's quite crazy so to
figure all of this out also I'm sure the
computer hates it yeah that's also I
thought but I decided just to keep it
simple and just just trade off and maybe
their computer hates it yeah King age
six in laughs and laughs and this is
what we did in that one here already
defended with the bishop okay then it
wants to go here and yeah b5 obviously
it's a move yeah I think that I think
we're all thinking b5 I don't know yes I
don't I doubt that this shouldn't work
but I mean yeah it's a it's a quick game
I thought a bomb leaned on let me just
keep it okay no just don't seem like a
Mario rope remove it is the SAC kind of
suspiciously and then sometimes it works
out really well I mean wow yes that's
that's a crazy move to have to try to
figure out in a really quick game yeah
so even if it's not right that might
have won the game quickly okay so
instead this happened and okay we're
just gonna calmly get her night into the
action here so here goes the night
nominee no no not Knight to g5 not yet
first you grab the stuff and okay
he's like I let's open it up he's
obviously hoping like we take some stuff
and my rook takes your queen but here
Knight to g5 and now black played the
losing move on this turn so I think
there's only one defense here at least
as far as I can see what would you guys
play here is black also what would you
play here as black probably get the rook
that give the exchange bag yeah yes I
think I think he has to go here yeah
I'll take this if you go here I'll move
somewhere yeah I don't know where yeah I
think I go here I'm kind of worried
about about being greedy here like
something like this because there's
gonna be some combination of like checks
and bringing this rook in that kind of
scares me but I think I can be a little
more calm maybe just played rook aged
three and you know I think okay black
sort of defended because okay as Mario
will prove in this position he actually
does have a very strong initiative in
this position so he played very very
well from here okay check and
unfortunately for Ken black has to move
away from defense of the e6 pawn which
is gonna be terminal here you grab it
okay and now another just really strong
move picking up the F pawn and now the
game's over
I assume there could be some more
resistance put up but in the game here
and one one last quiz what a Mario play
in this position let's we'll finish on
the nice strong note from Mario Queen f7
mate very strong move
okay so yeah fantastic game and I'm glad
you're able to come here we went over
some really really aggressive Mario
games and a big congrats on beating yet
another master just recently and thanks
for coming on the show you have any
final words for these fine people out
here continue to study chess play hard
and try not to take it seriously when
you lose just go over the game that you
have lost in progress yeah excellent
advice yeah thank you very much Mario
and if you like this video go ahead give
it a big thumbs up like share subscribe
and I think everybody for coming out
tonight